did you know that torashima the manga
editor behind the one and only Akira
Toriyama the man who literally invented
the name Dragon Ball Z just recently put
out a book detailing the ins and outs of
manga itself that's right this thing has
Blow by blow lessons and insights on the
construction of manga itself down to the
most Nitty Gritty details I have not
gotten my hands on this myself yet but I
really can't wait for it to be
translated and hopefully released for
English readers one day it's picking up
so much steam in Japan right now even
one punch manga's yusuke Morata has read
through it and had nothing but High
Praise